thank you all for the warm introduction
I'm honored and humbled to be standing
in front of you today because when I was
here as a graduate student it was very
common for me to plan my experiments on
Wednesdays around being able to sneak
out of lab in the late afternoon to come
to these talks so it's a little surreal
to be standing up here instead of
sitting back there but I hope to share
with you some of my experiences from the
last five and a half years or so with
emerald so I'm gonna do that I'm gonna
just tell you stories about the founding
of this company and the work that we've
done and how we think about the future
and just sort of go from there before I
get into all that I just wanted to lay
out to begin with the two themes that
I'm gonna touch on probably over and
over again the first is that startup
served hard they're not necessarily
glamorous or temporal if you look at the
history of Silicon Valley the companies
that have really changed things the
Intel's the variants the HP's did so not
over weeks or months they did so over
decades and I think that that's
something that isn't always appreciated
if you just look at these recent history
of this area so taking a much longer
view is something that we've always
tried to do at Emerald and something
that I'm gonna try to reinforce at a
number of different points in my talk
today the other theme that I'm going to
come back to several times is the focus
not on ideas but on execution I think
that we all sort of love this idea of
the sort of brilliant individual who's
you know just like generating ideas and
that's what everything comes from but
really if you're gonna do anything
significant it's much more about
execution and you can sort of think of
ideas as just a multiplier on top of
your team's ability to execute so I
would be remiss if I didn't start by
acknowledging the amazing team
we have at Emerald and a lot of the
things that you're going to see today
are a result of their hard work with any
company that has any sort of significant
length story arc the it's only the first
few chapters that really are about the
founders every one of our team members
that we've had during the company's
history deserves a chapter in the story
of this company as it happens the first
chapter to are about my co-founder and I
and that's where we'll start
so the our company is called Emerald
because in the summer of 1991 my family
moved to a house on Emerald Drive that
happened to be two houses away from
where my now co-founder Brian and his
family lived so we've known each other
since we were nine years old and have
grown up together and so one of the
reasons that we have such a great
working relationship is we've been doing
this for the better part of two and a
half decades as we when we were growing
up we heard all of these stories about
the history of Silicon Valley and
stories about the traitorous eight and
Fairchild and these companies that were
using technology to really change the
what our day to day lives were like and
also during this time when we were in
high school especially we got very
interested at this about this
intersection between computer science
and the life sciences but when we
applied to colleges most places that we
went where we told them that we wanted
to study at this interface we wanted to
double major in computer science and
biology they looked at us like they were
crazy like we were crazy like why would
you study those two things they don't
really go together so I feel very
vindicated that the last two decades or
so have more or less proven us right
about the importance of that interface
but needless to say we decided to
go to Carnegie Mellon because at the
time it was one of only two schools in
the country that had an undergraduate
program in computational biology so we
went to college thinking that we would
use this time to learn more about this
field and then start a company right
when we left and we had you know as we
got toward graduation we had an idea for
a company which in retrospect was a
really bad idea but nevertheless we were
talking to investors and entrepreneurs
mostly on the East Coast and just sort
of trying to figure out what we could do
to get this company off the ground and
the thing that we heard over and over
again was that no one will fund let
alone let you run a biotech company
unless you have three letters after your
name
so after hearing that once or twice or I
don't know 27 times we were just like
alright screw it we'll go get PhDs so
Brian went to Scripps research in San
Diego and I came here to Stanford and I
was not a particularly I'd not have a
particularly like fantastic graduate
career I think my research advisor would
agree with me on that I was a pretty
middling graduate student but the thing
that graduate school gave us was the
better part of five years to vet dozens
of different ideas for what our company
would do and not just what we would do
but how we would do it we spent a lot of
time thinking about what a research and
development organization in the life
sciences would look like if you were
starting from scratch in the 21st
century and it was really useful during
this time to be able to pick up the
phone and call someone else and
especially after like a particularly bad
day and just say I don't think the
Emperor's wearing any clothes and have
the person on the other line say you
know what I think you're right I do
think it's ridiculous that we're using
instrumentation that costs hundreds of
thousands of dollars and the way that we
save the data that comes off of this
incredibly complex instrument is we
print it
and we glue stick it into a paper lab
notebook like having someone who would
tell you that like you're not that like
you're not the crazy one everyone else
is the crazy one is incredibly
validating there's a big difference
between being an individual you know in
the room sort of like screaming that the
world is mad and having someone else
going like no I think he is right so
that was a really valuable experience
for us and it can't be understated how
how important it can't be overstated how
important it was to have someone there
to have those discussions with so we got
toward the end of graduate school and
again had an idea for a company and so
we started talking to investors and the
thing that we found out very quickly was
that it takes money to get lab space and
lab space to get money and we didn't
have either of those things
so we ended up working out a deal in
principle with our alma mater Carnegie
Mellon because somehow there were still
people there who remembered us fondly
and we had worked out a deal in
principle for access to lab space and
some shared facilities and equipment in
exchange for what at the time was a
trivial percentage of the company and so
we were all set to sort of go back and
start this company in Pittsburgh so
Brian wrapped up at Scripps I still had
a couple weeks left final signatures to
get and things like that here and so he
came up crashed on my couch for as long
as he could but eventually my lease ran
out and so we moved into the a motel 6
on El Camino which has actually since
been demolished so you can't go find
this building anymore I think it's
something else now so so we were living
at this motel and at this point we had
sold were thrown out or given away
anything we owned that wouldn't fit into
our cars and so we're just sort of like
killing time while we're waiting to go
back to Pittsburgh and literally on the
day that we were scheduled to go back
through one of our advisors we got a
meeting with Peter teal
and we went and we were at this point
you have to understand this is the
summer of 2010 and so this was long
before Peter and his venture firm
Founders Fund published their manifesto
Peter was mostly known as the you know
the co-founder of PayPal and for being
the first investor in to spit in
Facebook
SpaceX had been successfully launching
rockets for a couple years at that point
but were not certainly did not have the
public profile that they have now and so
we were just kind of excited to meet him
and to tell him about what we were
working on and to you know get his
feedback and then we were gonna leave
for Pittsburgh that day so we had this
meeting with him at 4 o'clock and we
were hoping to be on the road for
Pittsburgh by 8:00 my goal was to get
out of California that night it's like
if we can get out of California tonight
that'll be a good start to our road trip
back to Pittsburgh and that'll be
that'll be good that's what we're going
to do and the the idea that we were
pitching to Peter is not the cloud
laboratory aspect that you're probably
familiar with the name of our company is
Emerald therapeutics and the original
idea was this completely novel anti
viral platform for curing persistent
viral infections and that probably
sounds extremely audacious and ambitious
and it certainly was and I'm not going
to go into the details of how it works
but needless to say the work on it is
going well and so we're pitching this
antiviral company to Peter and we get
partway through the pitch and he stops
us and he says I want I think that this
is a Silicon Valley company and I want
you to give me a week to convince you
that you should stay here instead of
going back east and so we said okay and
we went back to the motel 6 and we
booked another week and a week became
two weeks and we ended up spending that
entire summer living out of our cars and
every cheap motel from San Jose to San
Francisco while we went through
diligence with Peter and Founders Fund
we pitched the deal to other VCS in the
area
and we sort of generally just sort of
started to map out what it would be like
to be based out here so it was
definitely this was a definitely a bit
of a stressful time so remember that we
were right out of graduate school it's
not like we had a lot of savings so
we're doing this all on credit card debt
and moving around from motel to motel
every week the unsorted a operational
efficiency nut case I think is the
technical term and the way that we would
do things was we would we would live we
would book a motel for a week we would
at the end of a week we would move out
we would go to the Stanford coin wash
which still exists on El Camino and we
would do a week's worth of laundry and
we would use Hotwire to book the next
week's motel because we had figured out
that a week was sort of the optimal time
because if you did longer than that the
prices started to go up if you did less
than that then you were just moving all
the time and that was not really
sustainable this laundromat was actually
also our only real this in Starbucks
really where our only reliable sources
of Internet at the time so it was not
uncommon for us to do video conferences
with potential investors or potential
hires from this laundromat and we
learned after like this and it was also
pretty common at least on the weekends
for people to go there and literally
wash almost everything they had on so
probably the second time that some
half-naked person walked behind us on
one of these conference calls we decided
that we should probably just save these
for Starbucks so we're going through
this where we're sort of living out of
these motels and I would be lying if I
told you like this is a very fun story
to tell now but at the time it was
really stressful I mean I literally had
friends from high school and college
calling me saying hey I heard you
finished up at Stanford what are you up
to now and the only honest response I
could give them was I'm homeless and
unemployed so this is a picture that the
reason that this picture exists is
because one of my mantras during this
time was I'll buy new socks when we
raise funding so my clothes got pretty
threadbare during this time and at some
point Brian's car got broken into and
they stole a bunch of this stuff and I'm
it was just a very it was a stressful
time both from a sort of professional
standpoint and also from a financial
standpoint really I mean I made myself
everyday go on to my bank's website and
check my credit card balance just so I
never lost touch with that reality of
like exactly what this is costing us but
it does have there is like a happy
ending to this part of the story at the
end of three months we ended up closing
a round of financing with Founders Fund
as the lead investor and one of the
terms in the term sheet was that the
company was going to had to be based
between San Jose and San Francisco so it
was sort of decided that we would be a
Silicon Valley company at that point so
when we started I still consider it a
minor miracle that we were able to
raised funding at all and but the amount
that we raised was substantially less
than you would normally raise for a
biotech company as ambitious as what we
were planning with emerald it was
something like four to five times less
than what you would typically do for a
project like this and we were kind of
fine with that because remember we had
spent the better part of five years
thinking about how we could more
efficiently run a research organization
so there were two aspects to this
initial lab that we built and the way
that we were going to organize our
company so the first was automation we
were going to take every experiment and
automate it to the point that it was
push a button walk away and so for you
engineers out there that may not seem
that revolutionary but you have to
understand that historically scientific
equipment is designed to have a person
standing in front of the instrument
while it's running and so we decide
none of that for us we are going to
we're going to make sure that the people
that we hire actually spending their
time thinking about the science rather
than babysitting machines and we were
helped in this endeavor by a lot of
advances in the scientific
instrumentation hardware business around
something called high-throughput
screening so high-throughput screening
is something that pharmaceutical
companies do to test literally millions
of compounds to see which ones are good
leads for new drugs the problem for us
was that most of these instruments are
meant and more specifically the software
on most of these instruments as meant to
do the same experiment a million times
but we weren't doing screening we were
going to use these for one-off
experiments which meant instead of
having an instrument do the same thing a
million times we wanted that instrument
to do a million different things once
each so that involved a lot of sort of
fighting with and working around the
instrumentation software so and that
dovetailed nicely with the second the
second sort of key tenant of how we were
going to run our company differently
which is that we were going to teach all
of our scientists how to write software
and the reason that we wanted to do that
we were sort of of course trained in
both of these things but over you know
about ten years we had seen this growing
divide as the datasets from scientific
experiments got bigger and bigger there
be there started to be this divide
between the people who generated data
and the people who could analyze data
and that seemed like a really scary
place to be and it seems like the key
sort of break point was once your data
got too big to fit in Excel and it had
to go into a database and now you need
to write sequel queries all of a sudden
it went over the fence to a
bioinformatics expert and we knew that
we certainly wouldn't have the headcount
to have a totally separate department
for that and it just seemed both
inefficient and just wrong to have the
people who were designing and running
the experiments not be the people who
are analyzed
so we taught everyone how to write
software in a very high-level language
we weren't teaching them how to do
memory management or anything like that
we used what was then called Mathematica
what is now called the Wolfram language
which is sort of like the Cadillac of
data processing languages and it enables
you to do some really powerful stuff in
just a couple lines of code so that was
the we have eight we had and actually
still have a two to three week training
class to sort of get people up and
running and using this for analyzing
data and doing other things that make
people efficient scientists more
efficient scientists so one of the the
first thing that we did so we had this
team of you know molecular biologists
and chemists and geneticists and we had
taught them how to write software and
just sort of like let them loose to
build tools to not only do the research
but also build tools to make themselves
more efficient and so the first thing we
did was we just built a database where
you could push and pull data from any
instrument in the lab so that's in most
labs where I worked the data from an
instrument just lived on the hard drive
where it was generated and so now
everything was pushed to a central
database and then anyone could pull down
and look at that data but that wasn't
enough so we expanded that and we built
this linked data system that include
where pieces of data were linked to the
analysis that was done on them and then
over the course of about two or
two-and-a-half years that just expanded
to sort of consume all aspects of the
lab so it that included inventory
management sample tracking
instrumentation Diagnostics and sort of
the last piece of the puzzle to fall was
protocols so we started thinking of
protocols is just more data so our
scientists would sit at their computers
they would design experiments and they
would design the experiment that they
wanted to run and then that would
generate a machine-readable file that
would get loaded on to the instrument in
our lab and
then the only time you had to go into
the lab at all was to make sure that
that instrument had the the samples were
in the right place and it had enough
consumables and the buffers were hooked
up and that was it the instrument would
then just run by itself and you could
actually focus on analyzing data from
previous days or what your next
experiments would be and we started to
see efficiency games because our
scientists weren't really spending time
in the lab we started to see efficiency
gains like people running five to seven
times the number of experiments that I
could run on like a given day as a
graduate student
they were routinely doing that using
this system so at that point we kind of
looked around and said there's way more
value in this system than we can capture
just by using it as an internal tool we
should make this available for all
scientists so people anywhere in the
world can use software to enter commands
for experiments that will then get run
at our central facility and then we'll
just send them back the data along with
a whole suite of tools for doing data
analysis and visualization so we at that
point we actually reorganized the
company so it's very important to point
out that we did not pivot so we didn't
go away from the therapeutic we just
added on we branched so we added another
mission to the company and reorganize
things such that we have our and that
exists to this day we have our research
team and we have our cloud laboratory
team and in many ways the research team
is sort of customer zero for the cloud
laboratory so we were really sort of
like pushing at the limits of what we
could fit into this small into this
small lab space and so last year we
expanded into a much larger facility in
South San Francisco that we are still in
the process of expanding both in terms
of capabilities and capacity and trying
to get to the point where we can we can
actually run experiments for larger and
larger fractions of scientists so that
sort of takes us off to
now and so what I'd like to do in the
second part here is just tell you some
stories from both about building culture
and around and around to sort of more
present-day aspects of emerald so there
are three things that I'm going to touch
on the first is the benefit of having a
co-founder the second is something that
I call our contrarian truths and the
third is our fresh eyes Journal so
before to sort of understand the value
of a co-founder you have to understand
risk so every startup that's doing
anything remotely innovative is
inherently risky because there are a lot
of smart people in the world and there
are a lot of smart companies in the
world so just be I think it's a I think
it's wrong to think that like large
companies are not innovative or don't or
you know are somehow like not as open to
change as as others because there are
really smart people that work at these
companies and so there's probably no
idea that you'll have that someone else
probably someone at one of these giant
companies hasn't already had the
difference between you as a start-up
founder as an employee at a young
startup and then is that you said I
think that's a good idea I think we
should do that whereas they said no way
like that'll never work or that's a dumb
idea or it's like it's not time for that
so that's really the difference is that
you you decided like where everyone else
said no you said yes and so that means
just by its very nature that you're
going to be faced with some suboptimal
sets of choices in your decision making
because there's no there's no sort of
prescriptive path to startup success you
know and that's very weird for people it
was kind of weird for me so you know you
go through high school you know you do
these things you know that will like
make you like a successful high school
student
same thing in college kind of same thing
in graduate school but with a startup
it's kind there is no there is no
formula that you can follow that will
guarantee you success and oftentimes
that means that you're faced with a set
of decisions and you have option a and B
and what you really want is option C but
option C doesn't exist and so it's
really valuable to have someone who
could say like listen both of these
options are bad but which one is the
least bad like and to be okay with have
to have someone tell you that it's okay
to take a path that you know isn't great
but that you just sort of have to it's
sort of the reality of the situation
that you have to take this sort of like
route that you know is not optimal so
that's one of the really valuable things
about having a co-founder just someone
who can sort of share that burden with
you and similarly there's a time in if
any of you are thinking about or have
started companies and you're lucky
enough to have a good co-founder you
will have I promise you will have this
interaction where you will go to your
co-founder and you will say we are
screwed like for reasons x y&z we are
totally screwed and like the you know
the sky is falling and like this is it
for us and their day of one job in that
situation is to say it's gonna be
alright don't worry about it like here
are the things that we're going to do
like just like we'll get through this
because that happens a lot and all these
things that seem like you know dire
situations end up not being but when
you're so invested in the company
yourself it really feels like everything
is a crisis especially early on so again
your job as a co-founder is to say it's
going to be alright one of the other
things that I want to touch on is
something that we call our contrarian
truths at Emerald and this sort of
relates back to that idea of risk so
this is not sort of novel to me I
actually think this is something that
Peter has talked about publicly before
but it's very important for your company
to define the things that make you
different from the rest of the world so
by definition you're clearly thinking
about things differently or else you
know someone else would have probably
already done this idea you've already
said like I actually think this is a
good idea so that's that sort of the
first thing that makes you contrarian
but the other it's important to
establish what those things are for your
company and to get buy-in from everyone
on those things so I'm just gonna list
the things that are our contrarian
truths emerald and it's a you'll notice
that there aren't any things here like
quality first because quality first is
that's a great you know mission
statement to have or a great thing to
hold up for your company but it doesn't
actually make you unique the point of
this exercise of sitting down with your
early employees and saying what are the
things that we believe in these four
walls that everyone else outside of them
thinks we're crazy for for thinking and
that's it's a really valuable exercise
it's important thing to point to as your
company grows and matures to have this
as sort of a cornerstone of culture so
the last thing that I want to talk to
you about in terms of the sort of
present-day stuff is something that we
call our fresh eyes Journal and this is
something that came out of the idea that
we have all of these amazing employees
and we wanted a way to capture their
sort of initial feedback on the company
because when you're when you're in
something and you're working at
something for years
things that seem bizarre and unusual to
other people just begin to see comp
seem commonplace to you and so it
becomes very easy to sort of to become
immune to things about the way your
organization operates that are strange
or maybe incorrect so one of the things
that we do is every employee who joins
Emerald gets one of these journals and
they keep it for their first quarter
at the company and so anytime they see
something that seems weird to them some
issue something that we do that seems
unusual they write it down and then
they're tasked with going and talking to
other people at the company and saying
why do we do things this way like what's
our reasoning for doing this and then
once they do that then they have to say
like okay I like I understand that I've
like reframed that in my own words but
are there still remaining issues given
that rationale and if there are they
have to come up with some potential
solutions so what are some ways that we
could that we could fix this what are
some things that we could do better and
then after three months they that get
sent to me and my co-founder and also
their their manager and we read them and
reading these things is painful and the
reason it's painful is because you know
when you when you're building a company
you grow to love it and so you sort of
apologize to yourself for its faults and
you make excuses for it and you and so
having people point out to you the
things that you know you can see are
actually wrong with that thing you love
is a very strenuous and stressful
process but it's also a really healthy
one because it stops us from drinking
our own kool-aid and from getting to
this point where we're sort of in this
echo chamber because everyone has just
bought into everything or has sort of
been bullied into like the way that we
do things so we found this to be an
incredibly useful exercise the one thing
I will say is my some of my co-founder
insists that if you decide to do this
that reading a fresh highest journal has
a two-drink minimum so so you've been
warned so the last thing that I want to
talk to you about is a little bit
forward-looking so I assume
that all of you have heard of Moore's
law right anyone not heard of Moore's
law all right
so Moore's law tells about the is about
the density of transistors on microchips
but really you can think of it as
describing the reduction in cost of
these chips over time of computing over
time has anyone heard of Eros law all
right we have a couple so arune's law is
something that we have in the life
sciences and this comes from a paper
that was published in 2012 but actually
we've sort of known about this for
longer Brian and I used to talk about
this all the time in graduate school and
eroom's law is essentially the opposite
here Ohm's law says that the cost of
getting a pharmaceutical approved
doubles every nine years that's kind of
scary so just to give you a sense this
has been happening since 1950 and now
we're at the point where getting a drug
developed costs on the order of two
billion dollars depending on what study
you read so how can this be have
happened for 60 years how has the
industry not collapsed under its own
weight well it's because our spending on
health care has also increased
exponentially during that time and the
pharmaceutical companies can correctly
say that there are only a tiny fraction
of this problem and they're right but in
2004 our per-capita spending on health
care in this country was ninety five
hundred dollars per person that so the
the spending on health care that's not
an infinite resource at some point we
can't spend more per person on health
care we'll just be spending all of our
money on health care and the point at
which that at the point at which that
happens and that intersects with this
exponential from aru's law means that it
could become financially in
feasible to make new drugs and just to
give you a sense like this is not like
something that's going to be like your
children's problem or your children's
children's problem in in 1943 I'll be
sick in 1943 in 2043 I'll be 60 years
old and hopefully will still be alive if
this if the if you room's law continues
it'll cost 16 billion dollars to develop
a drug at that point that means that
only the most like valuable drugs are
worth making it there's a there whole
swathes of things that just aren't worth
discovering at that at that price point
and so that's a really scary thing and
that's a problem that we have to solve
so just to show you that I'm not all
like gloom and doom there is actually a
sort of silver lining hiding here so if
you look from basically the late 80s
through the late 90s you see the only
point in this graph where things kind of
level out and that's where the first
wave of biotech drugs sort of came
through the market and biotech drugs
like like antibody-based drugs are
different in that they it's a completely
different like motive action it's a
completely different platform from
traditional small molecule
pharmaceuticals and so that's really a
key to solving this problem is new
platforms for drugs and that's what we
wanted to do that's what we are doing
with emeralds therapeutic platform and
our goal with the ECL is to actually
make it easier for people to focus on
running the world's most efficient
laboratory so we can make it easier and
cheaper for scientists to do research to
discover new platforms so that we can
help reverse this trend so it's kind of
a still kind of a downer note to to end
to talk on but I really want to I hope
that you've gotten the point from this
that startups are hard they are hard
emotionally they can be hard financial
and there are much more sort of like
pleasant ways to live your life but
there are really difficult and really
important problems out there that you
can help solve and if you think that you
can contribute to fixing this or other
problems like this than it is absolutely
worth it
Thanks
okay I'll ask the first question sure so
I don't know can you go back to the
slide with the contrarian truth yeah
because those are all really interesting
maybe you could share a couple of them
and give some insights on where they
came from
absolutely so let's see where were a
couple of my favorites so so we'll just
start with the first one so one of the
things that was very important to us
when we were starting is that we were
going for people who were we were not
starting departments or hiring people to
do a singular job we called I think all
of our first hires were the job title
was a molecular engineer which is as
ambiguous as it sounds and the idea was
that you weren't like a chemist or a
biologist it was we had to solve
problems across disciplines and so we
never wanted people who were just like
I'm a biologist I do biology that's all
I do and we told people from the
beginning that we expected them to not
only come in willing to do you know
certain work but also to educate the
other folks on the team about their
particular expertise and also to learn
from others so we had you know people
who had backgrounds in applied
mathematics and you know organic
chemistry and molecular genetics and
they the whole point was to bring those
disciplines together not to silo them
apart which is a pretty common thing in
a lot of in a lot of companies see
another another favorite one that I like
is is no black boxes there's a there are
some great packages out there especially
in the bioinformatics world for like
solving things we're like you give it
these inputs and you get these outputs
out we wanted to make sure that we
always understood the sort of guts of
what we were doing and that there was no
there was no sort of idea of like oh I
just like run things through this filter
and it comes out and you know who cares
how it happens in the middle so
always having sort of like control of
the entire intellectual pipeline was
always really important for us yes
didn't quite paint a full picture of how
customers use your services sure so we
have a software application that
scientists can download and when they
were actually very capacity limited
right now so not anyone can download it
but when you have the software
application you design an experiment by
specifying all the variables as if you
were standing in front of that
instrument yourself anything you could
do if you are standing in front of the
thing in your lab you can those are all
variables that you can set using our
software once you do it goes into a
queue at our facility and once the
instrumentation is available for that
experiment it gets run with every
variable every scientifically relevant
variable being captured with robotics
and automation and then once that's
completed the data is sent back to you
and the software actually also has this
very deep data analysis plotting and
visualization package so you can
actually analyze that data in a moral
high throughput manner yeah absolutely
so the question was do I still think
it's true that you need three letters
after name that you need a PhD to run a
biotech company I didn't think it then I
just understood the sort of reality of
the situation I think that the industry
is starting to change around that but by
and large it is more or less still the
case I think the thing that I have the
thing that I've come to understand is
that it's really much more about the
types of the places that biotech and
pharma startups usually come from is
they typically get
bun out of academic labs they're not
typically started by sort of like rogue
graduate students or postdocs so even if
you have a PhD trying to like start a
company right out of school is
relatively unusual there are plenty of
counter examples to that but I think
it's still more the exception than the
rule yeah if Abrams law continues do you
think that there will be a point save
cost two hundred fifty billion dollars
to approve a drug do you think at that
point might start moving out of the
United States to get an approved
elsewhere because it's too
cost-prohibitive with the regulation
system sure so the question was if eros
law continues will pharmaceutical
companies start moving out of the United
States and getting approvals elsewhere
is that a fair summary so I I really
don't think so
because the cost of the approval is only
a small fraction of that I mean you can
actually look at this and see the places
where we're sort of regulation got
tighter like in the late 60s with with
all the rulings around Follette amide
like you know you can see sort of like a
sort of minor like changing the graph
there but this is not driven this is not
the FDA's fault this is not a regulation
this is not purely a regulation issued
this is an issue with our ability to to
develop novel and viable drugs so I
don't think that getting approval the
problem isn't that it's so expensive to
get approvals here the problem is it's
so expensive to make a drug that is
efficacious yeah could you elaborate a
little bit more on the time in your
company when you you realize you wanted
to add branch and create the cloudy
about for this thing like I'm trying to
you've started this new thing and you
have with this idea of like where it's
going to go and how much does it take
yep and then now you're like oh but we
also yeah like I'm sure like we
organized internally sure so the
question was about what the internal
reorganization process was like around
branching the company into two missions
instead of one so it was it was actually
a really liberating thing for a lot of
our team members because before that
everyone came in on a given day and said
like okay am I going today am I going to
work on pushing the research for the
therapeutic forward or am I going to
work on building the system that will
make it easier to do more research
tomorrow and that was a very there was a
very sort of personal thing for people
some people really gravitated toward the
former and other gravitated toward the
latter and it was just it was a balloon
as a point of stress for everyone of
like what should I actually be working
on today which of the you know which of
these is more important on this a given
day and so when we went through that
reorganization first of all it was
relatively straightforward like who fell
on the sort of like therapeutic side and
who fell on the cloud laboratory side
based on sort of where their preferences
to answering that question lay and it
made it really clear to people like what
they were supposed to be doing on any
given day and so it was actually a very
sort of sort of a relief I think for a
lot of people because we had even if we
hadn't said that we were going to turn
this into a commercial product we were
still building it internally so from
that perspective not much changed to
accept more clarity around like what
your job really was yeah
yeah so when or if you're the
therapeutic portion comes up with your
drug that's gonna be awesome sure you'd
like to use probably terrible it's like
cloud lab or that kind of techniques to
do all the carbon case and things you
need to do already get the approval do
you think that you're gonna have any
problems being that different with when
you eventually submit to the FDA or and
they're gonna be happy with how you're
running your I certainly think so I mean
we're actually from the cloud lab side
of it we're actually talking to a number
of large pharmaceutical companies who
are interested in working with us and in
terms of like running their early
experiments and one of the really
valuable things to them is that we have
full traceability of all of our samples
all of the experiments all that is
captured encoded in a database which is
far which is extremely rigorous and so
well obviously have to have those
conversations with their necessary
regulatory agencies in advance of
submitting anything through our system
to them but I think that the the sort of
trace history and the the full like
scope of being really able to track a
sample through its entire lifetime is
going to end up being valuable not a
liability in that in that scenario so
the question was do I think that
regulatory agencies will mandate moving
toward the kind of tracking system that
we use for everyone I think there were a
long way away from that I mean these
companies that have been doing this for
literally over a hundred years or you
know still around for a reason so I
think that change in this industry tends
to be slow but we'd certainly like to
help you know accelerate things however
we can
yeah you talk very positively about
having a co-founder what else
difficulties sure so I wouldn't
necessarily recommend anything to anyone
one of the things that I've purposely
tried to do today is to just tell
stories not give you advice whenever you
know we have some fantastic advisors and
mentors and I always find it much more
valuable when people just tell stories
because advice is sort of codified scar
tissue and it sort of like I did this
and it worked so you should do this or I
did this and it failed horribly so don't
do that so I can only tell you what my
experience was it's certainly been
helpful to me and has kept at least some
of my hair as short as it is not gray so
I've had a very positive experience with
it I can't imagine ever starting a
company without a co-founder but that
doesn't mean it's right for everyone
yeah yeah so that actually so you're
talking about right here perhaps yeah so
that was actually the I believe that one
I think that that dip in the graph was
actually there was a period where the
FDA cleared a lot of pharmaceuticals
much faster because many of them were
early HIV drugs so they were antivirals
for preventing HIV so this is big push
to get a lot of these through clinical
trials so there was this sort of
anomalous dip in the graph from that
sort of one time or few time event yeah
so how do you solve the problem when
you're there cute excited wants a new
feature and your customers of your cloud
one feature is kind of you prioritize
sure so the question is how do we
prioritize work when our therapeutic
side wants certain features but external
customers maybe want different features
we have a pretty holistic road
map and so we solicit input from all of
our users whether they be internal
external I would say that at this point
the system for the internal users is
pretty feature complete given that
they've been it was sort of built for
them from the start and expanding to
more types of experiments is something
that we want to do for sort of everyone
else but the core set of experiments
that we started with on the system were
built so that the research team could
operate in this way sure sure so the
question is about pricing and like
whether or not a graduate student can
afford to run experiments on this system
and the answer is it's really sort of up
to you as the scientist one of the
things that's really important to us is
that we're always go aligned with our
users so rather than just offering a
price list the price of running an
experiment is really a function of the
experiment you decide to run so it's a
function of the amount of instrument
time you use the amount of reagents that
you consume the amount of waste you
generate and the amount of set-up time
that your experiment takes so you can
run scientifically identical experiments
that costs dramatically different things
on the system so if you're willing to
take the time to actually design
efficient experiments then it's
absolutely accessible to to someone like
a graduate student and furthermore the
really important thing for us in terms
of cost is addressing the sort of total
cost of doing research so our so the the
idea is to look at sort of your budget
holistically and how much you can do how
much a single researcher can do with
like a given budget and
from that standpoint from an efficiency
standpoint I think we always win sure
yeah that's so the question is what were
the biggest lessons in recruiting and
hiring so the biggest and probably most
contrarian one was to be very wary of
people with 4.0 GPA Zoar who have like a
made an amazing publication record in
graduate school people who have sort of
been unmitigated successes throughout
their careers and the reason is and this
isn't like a it's not like we exclude
anyone for this reason but it does make
us take sort of a a harder look at a
candidate because as I as I hope you've
gotten from this talk startups are hard
and we want people who can like
persevere and who have grit and who
aren't used to things working well for
them
one of our one of our scientists had a
pretty like rough go as a graduate
student I think had like basically had
two pretty major failed projects before
the projects that she actually like was
sort of the cornerstone of her thesis
and that was like a huge like that was a
huge plus for us because and she is like
in not only brilliant but also like very
tenacious and just like does not let go
of things and so that is really a huge
value in an employee and a start-up so
that's probably the thing that we look
for the most
yeah so uh turn the starter page before
we had a kannada always like the
customer validation problems like now
like how many people talked to you and
at what point did you decide they're
like sure so the question was what was
the customer validation process like for
the for the cloud lab so we sort of had
remember this was just an internal tool
so we started just building the things
that we thought we that we needed to run
our own research and the idea was that
you would be able to hand this to
another team of three or four
researchers like our current research
team is and they could use it to you
know push a drug up into the point where
it was ready for animal studies and
clinical trials so I would say that it
sort of came you know it was already
pretty beat we had a really good sense
of the features that we needed because
we just had to build them for ourselves
and since then the other thing is we've
added have been pretty obvious stuff
like permission systems so that you know
you can't see everyone else's data on
the system so we've certainly had
conversations with early users and with
you know we've had these conversations
with folks that pharmaceutical companies
and that has that has certainly
certainly helped set some of our roadmap
but a lot of it was just from our own in
our own experience as scientists what we
would want in this product
yeah do you envision the future I
perhaps like how far is the future when
that facility that you showed example
like there's just nobody's there but
just like you know that gets through the
internet it gets an experiment it runs
it it streams the data back and then it
like cleans it up yep I think it'll be I
think it'll be a little while before we
get to that point the like internal like
legit so everything that's
scientifically relevant is always
captured in robotics and automation in
our lab but the logistics are handled by
our laboratory operations team which
works 24 hours a day seven days a week
to basically handle all those logistics
that our scientists would handle before
making sure that the right buffers were
hooked up to the instrument and that
samples got to the right place because
again all of these instruments are
basically built to have a person
standing in front of them and the
robotics challenge of being able to get
a plate of samples from any point in the
lab to any other arbitrary point in the
lab is extremely non-trivial and more
importantly doesn't really add value to
our user our goal at the end of the day
is to build features that add value to
scientists and so making a lab that is
totally automated and like has all of
these like robotics that are just
shuttling things around might one day be
economically viable I think it'll be a
very long time before that's the case
and that really that's something that
you know helps us but that really
doesn't help our user it doesn't give
them a better experience and make it
easier for them to run more experiments
or to run their experiments more
efficiently so we're much more focused
on the things that improve the
experience of doing science rather than
making the lab sort of automated for the
sake of being automated
please do I do thank you